failure hell disappointment discomfort
is a great learning tool fat on a shape
is secure I was everything everybody
said I was gonna be because the storm is
coming here right now and there's not a
soul out here but me the motivation
watch a top 10 with believe nation
what's that believe nation in seventh I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a man who went
from struggling in school growing up in
an abusive household and being
overweight to becoming a Navy SEAL and
one of the planet's most successful
endurance athletes he's David Goggins
and here's my take on his top ten rules
success vol 3 also a feature David and
two of my 250 for confident series where
every day for the next two hundred and
fifty four days I send you a morning
video for free to help you build
unstoppable confidence or highlight
excellence in the black community the
links to join are in the description
below you will never learn from people
if we always tap-dance around the truth
everything I didn't want to do is what
got me to where I'm at today
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one change your life I never forget one
time during a basketball game
there was this coach mr. trout he knew
me when I was a kid in that school I was
in third grade getting set back mr.
trout always loved me
this white man loved this that I mean I
don't know why you did but he was my JV
basketball coach my sophomore year the
visiting team was at our home stadium
who's at the end the game and the
visiting team who started chanting I was
only black person in the whole dadgone
stadium they started chanting
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that's all I
remember at that time in my life that's
all I remember
but not 42 years old I can look back on
that time with clear eyes in a clear
mind and see what mr. Cobb did for me he
went in that locker room when I was
crying upset and he cried with me this
white man cried with me but that time on
I didn't see that all I saw was red I
saw hey this whole town hated me
everybody's against me my mind lost it
and for some reason I couldn't sleep on
my bed until this day I don't know why
the floor felt so comfortable and at 22
21 years old I went from 175 pounds to
297 pounds fat out of shape insecure I
was everything everybody said I was
going to be that's what I was and it
makes you feel like so I got job
spraying for cockroaches at night I'm
not saying it's a bad job but I didn't
want to do it so for about six months I
went around to your local eateries
spraying for cockroaches this one night
I came home the first thing I do I walk
in my living room turn the TV on first
thing I do and then walk back to the to
take a shower and I would listen to the
TV I was always trying to take a shower
this day changed my life it held me
accountable for what I wasn't facing in
life they're going through Navy SEAL
training and I sat down I came out of
the shower and I sat down something
brought me back to sit down and watch
these guys going through hell I saw a
ton of them quitting ringing the bell
ringing the bell means you quit Navy
SEAL training
I saw him putting their helmet down this
went on through the whole show and it
finally got to the very end there's
about 15 to 20 guys at the very end and
this one statement changed my life they
were all sitting there and their dress
whites and this CEO this commanding
officer stands up in front of these men
and he looks sharp and he I could tell
you stood for something and he said we
live in a world where mediocrity is
often rewarded these men up here detest
mediocrity when you hear a statement
like that it forces you to think about
yourself
I wouldn't even mediocre I wasn't
anything I was at the bottom of the
barrel of life I chose the four-lane
highway for my life the easy route the
route that has gas stations the right
that has signs that say 20 miles to the
next service stop all this I chose that
route most of us choose the four-lane
highway when I was born it was also a
shovel over here in the corner that's
the no one wants to go into the shovel
they were to choose the four lane in
Howard that's it that's the nice rap
just shuffle means you're gonna hurt the
shovel means you're gonna suffer just up
of means you're gonna hit Rock a lot of
time and we all know what digging
through Rock is like when you hit a roof
you gotta get some more tools out if I
had one more tool just a shovel I was
choosing the four-lane highway this is
my decide to pick up that shovel that we
all decide not to take
I had to make a change in my life so I
say you know what I have to join the
military now we're on a Navy SEAL
training became the only person I
believe in history to go through three
Navy SEAL Heloise in one year rule
number two don't be your worst enemy
with your learning disability with your
dad beating you screaming at you
emotionally challenging your mind with
the racism you dealt with with the
different struggles you felt with
bullies
what was the Chun the hardest obstacle
to overcome
from up until about 15 16 the hardest
obstacle was myself I started realizing
more and more and more that all these
people were gone what was haunting me
was me I can't control my dad I can't
control the people calling me [ __ ] I
can't control all these things but they
were things that kept me down
it started become my reality my reality
was what they made out to be and I
became on the most important
conversation you'll ever have with your
life you know in your life is when you
have yourself mm-hmm and my conversation
was absolutely horrifying what were you
saying to yourself I'm dumb I'm nobody
my dad I mean my dad was great in mental
warfare a drunk insecure man will make
everybody around him feel like hell yeah
because he wants to give you no power
and that's why you were so mean and my
mom and myself and my brother because he
didn't want anybody to get above him
mm-hmm you want to keep you down low so
when you're growing up with all this
stuff all this hate and it wasn't the
beatings I kept the beatings all day it
was a mental torture so when at a young
age your your parents put a dialogue in
you of confidence or you're nobody
mm-hmm so that voice in my head was I'm
a loser and then it was confirmed when I
got in school and in third grade I was
falling behind they want to put me in a
special school yeah you know with kids
who can't learn
then was confirmed well you know what my
dad was saying so that confirmed it then
I started cheating so I realize you know
what I'm taking the easy way out again
yeah it starts no bond for there now the
kids are calling me [ __ ] mmm
but it wasn't all the kids so what
happens is you start to get this picture
that everybody hates you because your
reality becomes so so big that you know
you can't see the clear picture it might
have been three or four I see doing it
over and over but it was the whole town
yeah everybody hated me
so start world hates me that's right
yeah and that's when they that's what
became toxic and that is where I became
my worst enemy rule number three be
relentless hello everybody its Groundhog
Day again for David Goggins if you pan
it down here you see about three o'clock
in the morning and there's not a car or
a person in sight if you pan over here
it's the same thing not a car or a
person in sight people want to know
where I find my strength that where I
get my strength I get from a lot of
places though right now this morning I'm
getting it from there's none of them
that's up there's not a car there's not
a person everybody's in their bed sleep
dread and that is some Monday hate is a
Monday and I'm loving it I'm loving that
we're buyers getting weaker I'm getting
stronger
it's not about the running the swimming
to push up to sit ups it's about what
those things do for your mentality you
don't get better on a daggone couch you
get better by coming out here and
getting after every daggone day rule
number four find your motivation I was
obsessed with rocky rocky one in
particular and when I was a kid I come
every day and I watch this show rocky
and I would fast-forward with the little
VHS tapes to round 14 round 14 me up
like nobody's business
why this song came on right so I bought
the pull-up record I listened to the
song for 17 hours it's 2 minutes and 13
seconds
and I'm able to visualize and dream like
nobody's business and I know that I can
create a vision that many people can't
and I work for so the vision I had was
when a power creep beat the rocky beat
the stuffing he's kept fighting he was a
dumb fighter couldn't read couldn't
loves me couldn't read couldn't write
just punchy everything about him and
rocky beaches are probably stomach he's
in the corner but I was saying stay the
down and him getting up him getting up a
power creep raise his arms up and turn
around thought he won the fight he turns
around and sees this guy getting up and
it was the face of Apollo Creed that
changed my life the face of Apollo Creed
it was like just by them getting up not
winning just by him getting the up
Apollo Creed was his champ he's the best
rocky had taken his soul had literally
taken his soul his head goes down he
looks at my could what the are you I
wanted to be that not rocky I want to be
the guy that people looked at I don't
keep you've liked me or didn't like I
don't care but I said this was gonna
keep coming after whatever is in front
of him I wanted that I wanted that I
wanted that worse than anything in the
world
so that is I kept picturing me falling
down and getting up in every mother
called me [ __ ] I was dumped even
myself even myself I wanted to feel
something besides two feet I wanted to
just go to distance and that going a
distance pushed me to a point of where
now I go way past a distance rule number
five don't make excuses what was the
greatest lesson your mom taught you
growing up honestly the greatest lesson
she ever taught me is a lesson that she
does she doesn't know how much she
taught me because she wasn't much in a
teaching mode my dad took her soul but
what I did as a young kid is observed
everybody
I wasn't really smart in the books yeah
I was real smart when it came to life
yeah
and I was able to sit back and watch her
mistakes I was able to see how she
struggled through life and how I don't
want to struggle through life and I was
able to see she never picked me up
the biggest thing she did for me and
this is honest-to-god truth and she
doesn't even know she did it without I
bust my ass but I would fail you know
when I was at the bottom of the sewer
she never picked me up she never gave me
that cookie and said hey son you know
just go eat okay
no she didn't have time for that and
sometimes she gets upset when I talk
about my past because if it paints her
out to be not the best mom if I had any
kind of mom in that kind of environment
I would have never made mmm because she
forced me for ever reason she forced me
did you better figure this out are you
gonna be a statistic mom and this is
something she didn't sit down and tell
me I realized this this is the world
that is in front of me and what most
people do is they see this world and
they look at it as an excuse to get out
of it you know I started looking at it
as this is the ultimate training ground
for the rest of my life mm-hmm I have
all these valuable lessons because if
you look out in the world right now
today it's not a nice place I'm very
prepared for it yeah you are I prepared
for it I'm prepared for all the failure
coming my way I'm prepared for
everything my way and that's the biggest
lesson that she taught me by not
teaching me mmm by never saying it's
gonna be okay matter of fact she told me
exact opposite life sucks
rule number six become obsessed Stephen
Sal Joe was my recruiter I walked in way
97 he looked at me strangely and I said
I wanna be a seal and lucky enough the
guy looked at me and said let's see what
we can do he waved me I weigh 260 pounds
overweight
a guy said man there's a program that's
about to end that you can go and if you
make it through buds you're then go
active duty right and you'll be a seal
if not you come to home right
like yeah so anyway you gonna make out
lose 160 pounds less than 3 months how
did you lose the way in three months you
just run your ass off I couldn't run the
first thing about it was so I said it
myself I don't run for miles my first
run out the gate I'm gonna run for miles
I ran a mile a quarter of a mile walked
home sound the count's depressed I said
man there's no way I can do this but
what I realized though is I wasn't gonna
give up cuz I already given up too many
times and I thought about how would I
feel at 50 years old if you gave him now
if I gave up now I not to have you know
so I kept all this stuff in my mind you
know basically I started becoming
obsessed hmm I slowly it didn't happen
that night on the couch right over a
period of time I started becoming
obsessed with studying with weight with
being somebody was making people who
thought was gonna be nothing kind of
like feel like I became obsessed with
you have to make this right in other
person's could do it yourself so I
became obsessed with just being obsessed
rule number seven open the door before I
start a race I actually imagine myself
going through all my little checkpoints
I'm imagining all these different
emotions and things I'm gonna go through
so when that happens it just flows all
this imagery is so important in life if
you can see yourself doing something you
can do it if you can't see yourself
doing it usually you can't achieve it
everybody I get into I hit a wall in a
race that's so long if you hit several
walls and every time you hit a wall it's
a big deciding factor in that race or in
your life if you're not running and you
have a decision to make
if you can stop at that wall you can go
parallel left or parallel right you're
looking for that door and when you get
to the door you have another decision to
make
should I open it or should I keep it
closed if you keep it closed you made a
decision to quit if you open that door
you made a decision to carry on and
continue on with your journey or your
mission wherever you're on
and I always open that door because once
you open the door and you go through it
your mind resets and it gets you a few
more miles
I came to describe it to you how how you
feel when you know you're gonna complete
the hardest thing they're done your life
but the second you realize not to give
up your body gets back in tune again and
you're ready to go I have those mental
blocks all through the race but that's
when I smile - I signed up for that race
to see what kind of citizen I'm gonna
make and that's why I do it and usually
it's the season to keep on going forward
I have to experience life and that's how
I experience life rule number eight
gives back I started getting these
emails from people saying hey you know
what you changed my life that part
changed my life that part of your story
changed my life and because I have so
many different parts of my life that so
many people resonate with different
spots maybe it's doing be Spartan maybe
it's the bullying part maybe it's a
learning disability point maybe it's the
abusive parent part whatever it may be
some people draw from my story I started
getting these emails and I was like god
man you know I'm a big believer in
something more powerful than me I don't
know what it is but I'm not the end-all
so I was like I got to start doing more
hmm if I'm touching these people's lives
few people here and they're right maybe
I need to go out here and do some more
God put me in a very interesting spot of
life where he made hell my teacher
mm-hmm he made hell my teacher and a lot
of people don't understand that so I'm
trying to give people a different
thought process of life where failure
hell disappointment discomfort is a
great learning tool and many people
don't understand that and a lot of
people won't won't even understand this
interview we would get done with it but
it's these few moments in life that you
have like for me I always talk about it
rocky one round 14 that 1/2 minute in 13
second clip of
rocky getting up when Apollo knocked him
down that one clip when I was going
through a very bad time of my life
I saw what I wanted to be then one a guy
that one the one a guy that want
everything he did it was a guy that kept
getting up after being knocked down so I
realized if that 2 minutes and 13
seconds changed my life so I was I saw
something that I needed to be in the
world I was living in maybe my story
will give someone to 2 minutes and 13
seconds they need to change their life
these are people live in a very
comfortable place that's fine don't
listen to me a lot of people are looking
for that two minutes and 13 seconds mm
and I might be that person and I believe
that we're all were all teachers for all
teachers and if you don't learn
something and give back we got like what
you learned
yeah what's the point of living you're
wasting yeah your ways that you give all
this knowledge of what you learned
something might think you're crazy
some people may you know may put a title
on you but it's it's it is you know if
there's a few people who are like you
know what I need to hear that mm-hmm so
you have to put yourself out there
rule number nine commit fully I often
talk about taking souls this morning
this person I usually train alone it's
for someone to run with me
I said 5:15 this morning comes their
stores coming in this way and the person
calls and said hey why don't we do it
tomorrow
taking souls is when I told him I'm
gonna run 15 today and I run with you
again tomorrow
that's what taking solace is about don't
worry about the elements and what's
going on you gotta get out there and get
it and that's taking souls and obviously
he wasn't the only one I fell about
taking the day off because the storm is
coming in right now
and there's not a soul out here but me
and rule number 10 the last time before
a very special bonus clip is find your
purpose
everybody's journeys different
everybody's journeys different I was on
a journey to see who David Goggins was
and that journey took me in some of the
hardest areas a human being can even
imagine and right now at 41 I'm the
happiest person on the planet because
you know I had to climb Mount Everest
several times just to look down on my
life to see what hell I came from and
that's what kept me going through all
this stuff like I am vision myself going
through like when I was a young kid and
they called me [ __ ] all the time that
got my dad beat the hell out of me and I
was a known self-esteem I had this
vision of if I can make it to where I
want to go imagine when I look back on
my damn life how proud I will be and now
I'm here and I'm able to look back on
this life I lived that many people will
never understand because why when you're
passionate they think you're crazy and
you can't even explain to people why
you're doing and why you did what you
did because you found your purpose and
once you find your purpose you can't
really explain it to normal people
because they don't understand passion
because they let
everyday life is going not really
finding their purpose so I become a
foreign language to people to think so
they put me a category view this crazy
no no no I'm passionate I found my
purpose in this life
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from David on how to overcome hardships
that I think you're gonna really enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point landing questions time to move
from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
business and if you're feeling bold
leave these answers in the comments
below here we go question number one
what is your purpose
number two how can you commit fully to
it and number three what excuse do you
need to get rid of to achieve it
you genuinely are legit badass right at
one point in time you were a legit
terrified person yes so what was the
process like how did how did you step
forth well it's a it's a long process
right my dad beat me was growing up we I
was the first black baby born in this
hospital called Millard Fillmore in
Buffalo New York my dad owned skating
rinks he owned bars he ran prostitutes
from Canada to Buffalo New York my dad
was a big-time pimp big-time anything
bad about a person big-time hustler he
was American you know that I'm with them
Denzel Washington he was that but not
that bad right yeah he wasn't that big
but that's what it reminds me of he was
that kind of guy and beat the [ __ ] out
of me just you know I love my mom there
was an instant one time when my mom got
knocked on top of stairs and drug her
down the stairs by her hair and at six
years old
I'll never forget this in my mind I was
always afraid my whole life I was afraid
but I had this voice this this
conscience there would always be
battling me Stan hey you got to get up
and do something I didn't want to do
like I was just afraid but I would that
that voice would forced me to get up and
my dad you know I try to beat him up
whatever at 6:00 and I get my ass kicked
so this went on for several years and I
have a big time learning disability can
my dad didn't believe in us going to
school so my dad it was about the
business the skating rink in the bar so
this game you köppen about seven o'clock
at night and this is when time I was
able to walk so about five you know four
or five six years old eight nine and I
go to this you know skating rink
it's ten o'clock at night and I worked
the skating rink until 10:00 at night
and then we would scrape the gum off the
floors and we cleaned the whole skating
rink up and then my dad at the office
and my brother and myself asleep in the
office my mama go upstairs and worked
the bar until 3 o'clock in the morning
and then they cleaned the bar up so
after all that [ __ ] was done with going
to school who really happened
so when I went to school I was all kind
of you know my learned disability I had
social anxiety I was just a jacked up
kid from living in this tortured home
from the outside looking
and we lived in the all-white
neighborhood and then we would travel to
the ghetto of Buffalo New York with a
skating rink was that so we you know we
worked around mostly blacks and I lived
around mostly whites but no one knew
what was going on their house - on 201
Paradise Road you know it's crazy
[Music]
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple that would be like a little beacon
[Music]
if you want more David Goggins check out
the first top ten rules video we did on
him the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
okay it says somebody saying oh no
you're smart no no I don't say that to
yourself
I said to myself no I'm a dumb okay
Roger that